تقول الديموقراطية أنك لا تسكت
الناس ولا تخنق الأشخاص الذين
لا تغلق ميكروفوناتهم عندما
يتحدثون عن أهمية
قضية الحياة والتي تعود إلى هؤلاء الثلاثة هي
أننا نحتاج إلى قادة لديهم الشجاعة
للتصرف
في منازل الولاية وفي واشنطن العاصمة
والكونغرس الأمريكي
لديهم الشجاعة للتصرف
بدلاً من الجبن
[الموسيقى]
الأجنبي
بالأمس بدا وكأنه مسار من عصر جيم كرو
حيث رأينا رجلين من السود
يتقاتلان من أجل حياتهم المهنية يتقاتلان من
أجل سمعتهما  حياتهم السياسية
[الموسيقى]
نحن بحاجة لكم جميعًا وستؤثر قيادتك في
هذه الحركة على الأشخاص
الذين قد لا تقابل أبدًا أشخاصًا قد
لا يعرفون اسمك أبدًا ، ولكن بسبب
قيادتك سيستفيدون إلى الأبد
هذا يوم تاريخي لتينيسي  لكنه
قد يمثل يومًا مظلمًا للغاية بالنسبة
لتينيسي
لأنه تم إرسال إشارة إلى الأمة
ولكن لا توجد ديمقراطية في هذه الولاية
[موسيقى]